WORLD WAR II, VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE WILL GO IN
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S PLACE.
>> Bret: LET’S GET A REACTION
TONIGHT FROM THE SENIOR
REPUBLICAN ON THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE, GEORGIA
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS JOINS
US FROM TUCSON, ARIZONA, THANKS
FOR BEING HERE.
YOUR REACTION TO THIS IG REPORT
ON JAMES COMEY.
>> FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
FOLLOWED FOR TWO YEARS, IT
CONTINUES WITH THE LAST IG
REPORT SAYS, JAMES COMEY IS
SOMEONE WHO CANNOT BE TRUSTED,
HE HAD A PERSONAL VENDETTA, HE
BELIEVED HIS ROLE IN THE FBI WAS
ONE, HE IS THE ULTIMATE ARBITER
OF BEING JUDGE AND JURY OF
ANYTHING HE DID OR DID NOT LIKE.
HE CAN SAY HE DIDN’T LIVE BUT WE
HE CAN SAY ANYTHING HE WANTS TO,
KNOW HE DID.
HE LIED TO THE FBI, WE CAN TELL
HE LEAKED BECAUSE HE USED A
THE MEMOS OUT THERE.
THIRD PARTY MULE TO ACTUALLY GET
HE’S BEING DISINGENUOUS BECAUSE
YOU CAN SEE RIGHT THROUGH HIM.
THIS IS A JOKE, FOR HIM TO GO ON
TWITTER AND ASK FOR SOMEBODY TO
APOLOGIZE TO HIM -- WHY DOESN’T
HE TAKE HIS WHITE ROBE THAT HE
BEEN WEARING AROUND AND WHEN HE
GETS THOSE THINGS OUT FROM
LYING, MAYBE SOMEBODY CAN
APOLOGIZE TO HIM.
>> Bret: A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
WATCHING THE INVESTIGATIONS AND
ARE SAYING WHAT NOW?
WHERE DOES THIS GO?
DO YOU HAVE ANY ANSWERS?
>> I THINK WE ARE STILL THERE,
THIS IS ONE PART OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL’S REPORT, ONE
PART OF THINGS STILL LEFT TO
COME.
I TALKED ABOUT THIS WITH
McCABE, COMEY, THEY HAVE A LOT
OF THINGS TO WORRY ABOUT HOW
THEY HANDLE WHAT I BELIEVE IS
GOING TO BE COMING IN THE
COMPLETE PFIZER INVESTIGATION,
NOT JUST THIS PIECE THAT CAME
OUT.
I THINK AT THIS POINT IN TIME
WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE OUGHT
TO KNOW IS AFTER TWO YEARS OR
MORE OF GOING AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HAVING A DOJ
THAT WAS HARASSING AT EVERY
POINT, WE HAVE AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO SAID WE ARE
GOING TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS.
WE HAVE AND EXPECT HER GENERAL
CONTINUING HIS WORK AND A U.S.
ATTORNEY LOOKING INTO HIS
WRONGDOING, IF I WAS SOME OF THE
SCRUB CABAL I WOULD BE WORRIED.
>> Bret: AFTER HIS BOOK CAME
OUT IN APRIL 2018, I HAD
JAMES COMEY ON THIS SHOW
INCLUDING THE SPECIFIC HANDLING
OF THESE MEMOS.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO THIS
CLIP AND GET YOUR REACTION.
>> I SENT MR. RICHMOND A COPY OF
A TWO PAGE ON CLASSIFIED MEMO TO
GET IT TO THE MEDIA.
>> DID YOU LICK OTHER THINGS TO
MR. RICHMOND?
>> I DON’T CONSIDER WHAT I DID
WITH HIM A LEAK, I TOLD HIM
ABOUT AN UNCLASSIFIED
CONVERSATION WITH THE PRESIDENT.
>> THE UNAUTHORIZED DISCLOSURE
OF MY OFFICIAL EMPLOYMENT
OF ANYTHING RELATED OR BY VIRTUE
WITHOUT PRIOR WRITTEN PERMISSION
FROM THE FBI, THAT YOU HAVE
WRITTEN PERMISSION?
>> NO, I DIDN’T CONSIDER IT PART
OF AN FBI FILE.
>> YOU WROTE IT AS AN FBI
DIRECTOR, IT WAS A WORK PRODUCT.
>> IT WAS PERSONAL, I CREATED
TWO COPIES OF IT, I ALWAYS
THOUGHT OF IT AS MINE LIKE A
DIARY.
>> Bret: WHO ELSE DID YOU LEAK
THE MEMOS TO?
>> I GAVE THE MEMOS TO MY LEGAL
TEAM AFTER I GAVE THEM TO DAN
RICHMAN AFTER I ASKED HIM TO GET
IT OUT TO THE MEDIA.
>> Bret: YOU SAID IN THE MEMOS
I DON’T DO SNEAKY THINGS, I
DON’T LEAK, I DON’T DO WEASEL
MOVES, BUT WE CAN ARGUE WHAT A
LEAK IS BUT THAT’S A LEAK, ISN’T
IT?
>> IT’S NOT.
>> Bret: HERE’S WHAT YOU TOLD
CHUCK GRASSLEY ABOUT LEAKING.
>> DIRECTOR COMEY, HAVE YOU EVER
BEEN AN ANONYMOUS SOURCE IN A
NEWS REPORT ABOUT MATTERS
RELATING TO THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION OR THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION?
>> NEVER.
>> HAS ANY CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION RELATED TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR HIS
ASSOCIATES BEEN DECLASSIFIED AND
SHARED WITH THE MEDIA?
>> NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
>> Bret: AT WHAT POINT WERE
YOU MADE AWARE THAT SOME OF THE
INFORMATION WAS CLASSIFIED?
>> WHICH INFORMATION?
>> Bret: IN THE MEMOS.
>> SOMETIME AFTER I WAS FIRED.
>> Bret: WHEN YOU HEAR ALL OF
THAT, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> IT’S JUST SAD TO.
YOU TALK ABOUT WEASEL MOVES,
THIS IS THE ULTIMATE WEASEL.
TO TRY AND BLAME IT ALL ON OTHER
PEOPLE THAT I DIDN’T LEAK, HE
USED A MULE AND THAT’S WHAT HE’S
TRYING TO PORTRAY HIMSELF AS,
HE’S NOT.
JAMES COMEY KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT
HE’S DOING, HE KNOWS EXACTLY
WHAT HE DID, TO CLAIM THOSE WERE
PERSONAL DOCUMENTS.
HE SAID HE HAD NO PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PRESIDENT -- THAT TELLS ME HE’S
ADMITTING RIGHT THERE THAT HE
WAS IN AN OFFICIAL CAPACITY
BECAUSE HE DIDN’T HAVE A
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND THOSE NOTES WERE
TAKEN FOR INTENT BECAUSE HE
DIDN’T LIKE THE PRESIDENT, YOU
CAN SEE FROM THE PAST AND I
THINK THEY WERE USED FOR THAT.
FOR HIM TO CLAIM INNOCENCE AND
TO TRY TO GO BACK AND TRY TO
SPIN THIS, THAT IS A JOKE AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE RIGHT
THROUGH IT.
>> Bret: DEMOCRATS LIKE
CHRIS MURPHY FROM CONNECTICUT
SAY THANK GOODNESS HE KEPT THESE
MEMOS, THAT THE NATION IS BETTER
MEMOS, THAT THE NATION IS BETTEROFF FOR IT BECAUSE IT PRODUCED A
OFF FOR IT BECAUSE IT PRODUCED A
SPECIAL COUNSEL THAT DETAILED
THE RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE IN 2016
AND A WHOLE LOT OF OTHER THINGS
IN THAT REPORT.
>> I THINK THE SENATOR IS
MISTAKEN, WHAT HE DID WAS HE
STARTED SPECIAL COUNSEL BECAUSE
HE WANTED ALWAYS TO DISAVOW THIS
PRESIDENT AND MAKE SURE THIS
PRESIDENT WAS NOT ABLE TO
FUNCTION BECAUSE HE’S ALWAYS
HAVING TO LOOK OVER HIS
SHOULDER.
THE REASON HE KEPT THESE MEMOS
WERE NOT FOR NOBLE PURPOSE -- WE
NEED TO GET THIS OUT OF OUR
HEADS.
HE WAS NOT ACTING AS
CAPTAIN AMERICA, HE WAS ACTING
AS A GUTTER AGENT BECAUSE HE
WANTED HIS OWN AGENDA PUT
FORWARD.
THERE WAS NO RUSSIAN COLLUSION,
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL REPORT FOUND
THERE WAS NO TIME OF THE
PRESIDENT DID ANYTHING OR HIS
TEAM DID ANYTHING WITH RUSSIA
THAT AMOUNTED TO COLLUSION.
IF THAT HAS BEEN PUT TO BED.
IF MR. MUELLER HIMSELF WAS
TESTIFYING BEFORE OUR COMMITTEE,
HE WENT THROUGH WITH THE
DEMOCRATS AND HE WOULD GET TO
THE OTHER AND SAY I DON’T AGREE
WITH HER LEGAL CONCLUSION.
FOR MR. MURPHY TO WASTE
$30 MILLION ON THE WITCH HUNT
BECAUSE MR. COMEY DIDN’T LIKE
THE PRESIDENT, YOU NEED TO ASK
WHAT PART OF THAT WAS REALLY
GOOD.
>> Bret: DO YOU HAVE ANY
INSIDE KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT WHEN
THE REST OF THE IG REPORT IS
GOING TO DROP?
>> WE’VE BEEN THINKING IN THE
SEPTEMBER TIME FRAME, THOSE OF
THE INDICATIONS THAT WE HAVE AND
I THINK FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
I THINK FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,THERE WAS A CORRUPT CABAL AT THE
THERE WAS A CORRUPT CABAL AT THE
BEGINNING OF 2017 AT THE END OF
2016 AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND THE FBI -- THEY ARE
GONE.
THAT HAS NOW BEEN PUT TO REST
AND I THINK WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT THAT
CAN BE TRUSTED UNLIKE WHEN YOU
HAD JIM COMEY AS THE FBI